à la fin desquelles elles organisent une présentation
pour partager le résultat de leur travail, en toute transparence.
Et chaque jour,
chaque membre fait le point
sur ce sur quoi il travaille à son niveau.
Toute cette transparence peut sembler inconfortable,
car soudain, il n'y a plus aucun endroit où se cacher.
Tout ce que nous faisons est à la vue de tous.
Donc l'alignement n'est pas facile.
Et donner de l'autonomie n'est pas si évident non plus.
Un cadre d'une autre entreprise
aime raconter comme il était passé maître dans la surveillance des étapes.
Aujourd'hui, pour savoir comment les choses vont,
au lieu lire des rapports de situation,
il va assister aux présentations de ses équipes.
Et plutôt que dire ce qu'ils doivent faire,
il cherche des moyens de les aider.
C'est un changement radical
pour quelqu'un qui était maître dans la gestion des étapes.
« Mais à l'époque - dit ce cadre -
j'avais juste l'illusion du contrôle.
En vérité, beaucoup de projets dépassaient le temps et le budget alloués.
Maintenant j'ai plus de transparence,
et je peux corriger le cap en amont si besoin. »
Les cadres intermédiaires doivent eux aussi changer.
Déjà, sans paperasserie et Powerpoint,
Il y a moins besoin de cadres intermédiaires.
Et avant, il y avait l'idée de décideurs et d'exécutants.
Les employés devaient juste suivre les ordres.
Mais maintenant, au lieu de simplement gérer les gens,
ces cadres sont censés devenir entraîneurs-joueurs.
Donc imaginez, pendant ces 10 dernières années,
vous avez juste dit aux autres quoi faire,
et là, on vous demande de faire des choses à nouveau.
Clairement, ce modèle n'est pas pour tous,
et des gens très bien quittent l'entreprise.
Mais le résultat est une nouvelle culture
avec moins de hiérarchie.
Et tout ça, c'est un travail difficile.
Mais cela en vaut la peine.
Les sociétés avec qui j'ai travaillé,
apportaient de nouvelles fonctionnalités à leurs produits plusieurs fois par an.
Maintenant, ils ont de nouvelles versions tous les mois,
et en évitant la paperasserie et la bureaucratie,
L'organisation globale devient plus efficace.
Et finalement, si vous arpentez les couloirs de ces sociétés aujourd'hui,
vous ressentez juste une énergie nouvelle.
Ça fait comme si vous arpentiez les couloirs d'une immense grande startup.
Pour être honnête, elles n'ont pas encore crié victoire.
Mais au moins, avec ce nouveau modèle,
elles sont mieux préparées pour réagir aux changements.
Le monde devient plus rapide et plus complexe,
donc il nous faut réinitialiser nos méthodes.
Et la partie la plus difficile de ce changement n'est pas la structure
ou les méthodes, ou les procédures,
ni simplement ce que les cadres supérieurs devront gérer.
Les leaders vont être ceux, dans cette organisation,
qui vont embrasser le changement.
Nous allons devoir conduire le changement.
Donc la question est :
qu'êtes-vous prêts à abandonner ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)